Hi, I’m Indya and I’m here to show you
how to make sure you’re immunization compliant
in time for registration.
It’s an easy four-step process.
Step One: Make sure you have a signed and
verified immunization record.
If you don’t, start by logging into OPUS
with your Emory Net ID username and password
at O-P-U-S dot Emory dot E-D-U.
Click on the tasks tile to see your personal
“To-Dos List.”
Look for your immunization related to-dos,
follow the links to the Student Health Patient
Portal.
Sign in with your Emory Net ID and password
again.
Click on the immunization form link listed
on the Emory Patient Portal home page.
Download and print your school-specific immunization
form.
Have your doctor complete and sign it.
Keep the signed form handy!
You’ll need it later for step three.
Step Two: Complete the tuberculosis questionnaire.
Go back to the Emory Patient Portal home page.
Click on the tuberculosis questionnaire link
and fill it out.
Step Three: Enter your immunization dates
online.
Return to the Emory Patient Portal home page.
Click on the Immunizations Form link.
Scroll down and enter all your immunization
dates.
Hit “Submit.”
OK.
You’re almost done!
Step Four: Upload your signed and verified
immunization records.
Go to the bottom of the immunization form
where you hit submit to upload a healthcare-provider
signed and verified copy of your immunization
record.
Once Emory Student Health has verified your
records, OPUS will remove immunization tasks
from your to-do list and you’ll be immunization
compliant.
Verification can take up to five business
days, so plan accordingly!
Visit student health dot Emory dot E-D-U for
more information on being immunization compliant.
Thank you for doing your part in keeping the
Emory community healthy, and helping every
student be well and excel.